welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer security
practical measures
so in this video we're going to talk
about some things that you can
specifically do to keep yourself safe
online
there is going to be a little bit of
overlap in this video with the previous
videos but i did want to put all the
practical suggestions all in one place
i'm going to be going through this
pretty quickly so you know if you've got
questions definitely go back and check
on uh
our more extensive discussions on these
different mechanisms
earlier in in the quarter right so we've
seen
a bunch of pretty scary ways our
computers can get attacked
and so what can we do to protect
ourselves
all right so the number one thing is
definitely
keep your software updated it's super
simple
pretty straightforward and remember that
many attacks
are based on pre-existing ways of
attacking your computer so
there's lots of different tools out
there that people can just pick up
off the shelf and use it to to
attack a computer and so
if your software is updated you will be
protected against all
the attacks except for the zero day
exploits it's far more likely that you
will be attacked
using something that already exists and
has known about than
the things that we don't know about all
right um
definitely think about these password
recommendations when you are creating
passwords first of all use
different passwords for different
accounts remember
if you're just creating an account on a
random website you don't know who that
person is
and second even if that person's uh you
know
a good-hearted person they may not have
good security practices and your
password information may leak so
definitely
different passwords for different
accounts be super careful with your
email password and of course enter your
financial
passwords um use a good length password
the longer the password is the harder
it's going to be to break use
uppercase letters lowercase letters
numbers and punctuation
um consider using a passphrase instead
of a password
but remember for maximum effectiveness a
passphrase needs to contain just
a random sequence of words not some sort
of a phrase
not some sort of a sports team cheer
preferably not even something that makes
sense in the english language just a
bunch of random words crammed together
also consider using a password manager
use multi-factor authentication when
available
if possible choose the authenticator
option
either a cell phone app or a physical
authenticator
either of those is preferable to
receiving text messages
the text message system is not secure
but uh
using a text message based two-factor
authentication is still way better than
not having two-factor authentication
watch out for phishing don't click on
links and email messages
remember the email system is completely
insecure
that it's trivially easy to create a
pixel by pixel
exact reproduction of a website so just
because it looks exactly like your
bank's website doesn't mean it's your
bank's website
and that it's super easy to spoof the
email system and pretend to be something
that
someone you aren't um instead of
clicking on the link go directly to the
main website
uh type it in yourself don't copy it
from the email message
don't copy anything from the email
message or
call the company directly by phone
if you're in a sensitive position and
particularly concerned about security
don't forget about spear phishing that
was a type of phishing where
the attacker studied who you are and
figured out what sort of emails you
should receive and then crafted an email
specifically designed to get you to open
it
um use anti-malware software um
the operating systems have gotten a bit
better with having good
anti-malware software built in so
windows defender is actually considered
pretty decent
but you can get free anti-malware
software from stanford if you go to
ess.stanford
that's short for essential stanford
software
and you can get free software there
for maximum security you can consider
blocking javascript
this will make browsing the web a bit
more annoying but
it will enhance your security all right
that's it for our security lectures
i will talk to you all soon